hi Kelly my name's or creatinine my two  children Isabella  [Music]  we came up with something that seemed  perfect for your hashtag home not alone  and we decided or I sighs on day two of  our self-isolation due to the payment 19  that they were eating me out of house  and home  so I decided to create a price list for  our turkey shop in the kitchen all the  items they like snacking on in the code  if you pick your items yeah  damage your priest cost the own house  the options are slightly more expensive  that have the options are slightly  cheaper what would you like today yes  take right soon how much do you agree on  a steep interpret the idea is that the  girl at the table come to the items and  then calculate the change so a little  bit much as it saves my cupboards from  running out as well thanks say bye-bye  ready  [Music]  subscribe to my channel subscribe to my  channel subscribe to my channel  subscribe to my Channel please don't  make me keep going